Trascrizione: Agnese Giacomelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quante volte, nella vita,
avete pensato che una cosa fosse bella?
Ma vi siete mai fermati a pensare
al perché la vedevate bella?
Sulla base di cosa, dentro di voi,
è nato quel pensiero?
Nel mondo dell'arte, il concetto di bello
è qualcosa che mi ha sempre
affascinata e incuriosita.
Mi sono sempre chiesta
come certe persone fossero così entusiaste
nell'acquistare opere
che a volte sembrano
così assurde e concettuali
da risultare quasi incomprensibili;
eppure, ciò che ci avvicina
a un'opera d'arte,
piuttosto che a un'altra,
è proprio il vedere
la bellezza in quell'opera.
Quando mi chiedono che lavoro faccio,
e dico che sono un'artista,
so cosa tutti si aspettano:
che io rappresenti la bellezza
su una tela, su un quadro
o attraverso un'altra creazione.
La prima volta che mi hanno
commissionato un murales,
ero terrorizzata:
avevo paura di sbagliare,
di fare un'enorme macchia sul muro,
di guardare quelle persone
che avevano riposto la loro fiducia in me,
e vedere nei loro occhi la delusione.
La prima volta che dipingi
è come mettersi a nudo
davanti alle persone,
facendo vedere cosa hai dentro;
è un atto che espone la parte
più vera e interiore di te,
sottoponendola al giudizio altrui.
In questo modo, però,
non viene giudicata solo l'opera,
ma anche la persona che l'ha realizzata,
nella sua sfera più intima.
Per questo, credo serva molto coraggio
per mettersi a nudo;
ma è anche un atto liberatorio,
che rivela una parte di te
attraverso un'impressione sul muro;
rappresenta la te di quel giorno,
la stessa te che il giorno dopo
cerca di nuovo di uscire
attraverso il pennello.
Ed è così che, negli anni,
è diventato qualcosa
a cui non posso più rinunciare.
Ognuno di noi, da bambino,
ha riempito fogli di colore e pittura,
esprimendo liberamente sé stesso
e la propria creatività,
senza alcun vincolo.
Ma la maggior parte delle persone,
crescendo, ha smesso di dipingere.
E perché avviene questo?
Ho riflettuto su questa domanda,
e credo che il motivo principale
sia la paura del giudizio altrui.
Se la pittura è espressione di sé stessi,
forse si smette per paura di sentirsi dire
che quello che si è fatto è brutto,
e questa paura è sufficiente a frenarci
dal prendere un foglio, una tela
o addirittura un muro
e iniziare a dipingere qualcosa.
Credo che a un certo punto della vita
ognuno di noi smetta di esprimersi
davvero liberamente,
come faceva da bambino,
omologandosi alle persone
e alle convenzioni sociali
e spesso reprimendo
quello che ha davvero dentro di sé.
Quante volte ci soffochiamo
con una vita talmente piena di impegni
da non lasciarci il tempo
per pensare a chi siamo,
e alla strada che stiamo percorrendo.
Una frenesia che non ci lascia
il tempo di capire
se siamo davvero sulla strada giusta.
La pandemia, in questo senso,
è stata una doccia fredda per tutti.
Ci ha costretti a stare
davvero con noi stessi,
e ad auto analizzarci.
Per qualcuno, è stato come l'occasione
per fare pace con una persona
con cui non si parlava da anni,
avendo il tempo di chiarire
che cosa funzionava e cosa no.
È stata l'opportunità,
per tante persone, di reinventarsi,
di trasformare una passione
in qualcosa di più grande,
di esporsi attraverso i social,
di affrontare la paura
di essere svalutate.
Credo che a tutti noi servisse un momento
nel quale fermarsi
completamente e ragionare,
per capire che la vita
può essere ancora più bella,
se vissuta inseguendo le proprie idee,
le proprie passioni, i propri sogni.
Questo rende ogni giornata
parte di un disegno più grande,
uno scalino che ci porta
nella giusta direzione per noi
verso ciò in cui crediamo.
Per me dipingere è questo:
è esplorare me stessa
attraverso i pennelli;
è ricercare la bellezza
in ciò che faccio, ogni giorno.
Ma ho capito che la bellezza è soggettiva.
Ci ho messo un po' a realizzare
perché le persone hanno, sempre,
opinioni divergenti sulle mie opere.
Ma ora mi è tutto più chiaro.
Ognuno di noi guarda un'opera
come uno specchio:
ogni colore, tratto o movimento
smuove qualcosa di diverso
in ciascuno di noi.
Che può essere legato al passato,
o alle esperienze vissute;
ma anche allo stato d'animo
del momento presente.
Ogni opera smuove qualcosa in noi.
E secondo me,
la vera chiave per un artista
non è tanto il suo talento,
quanto l'empatia,
la capacità di riuscire
a capire le emozioni
che prova la persona
a cui è destinata l'opera stessa,
e tradurle in una forma.
L'arte per me è questo:
è capire ogni giorno me stessa,
e chi ricerca le mie opere,
scavando fondo e creando così
un linguaggio puro e autentico,
dove il pennello diventa il canale
delle nostre emozioni,
un mezzo che le fa uscire
e le imprime in un'immagine.
È per questo che l'arte è per tutti:
è qualcosa di fruibile
attraverso il linguaggio
universale dei sensi.
E quindi, tutti noi
possiamo godere della sua bellezza.
Si tende ad associare
la figura dell'artista
ad uno stereotipo ben definito:
ma vorrei sfatare questo mito.
Ognuno di noi credo che, a suo modo,
possa essere un artista.
La creatività la si trova ovunque,
in ogni professione e in ogni azione
che si compie con impegno e passione.
Per me, ritornare a vivere è questo:
saper riconoscere il valore
di ogni piccolo gesto
che si compie per realizzarsi.
Non è solo una questione di vita sociale,
o di poter ritornare
alle attività di tutti i giorni.
La vita è piena di cose belle
che spesso ci sfuggono,
ma penso che la chiave
per vedere la bellezza
sia cercare la piena armonia
dentro di noi.
Perché solo amando ciò che abbiamo dentro
riusciremo ad amare
ciò che è attorno a noi,
vedendolo totalmente,
incredibilmente,
bello.
(Applausi)